Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Quand mon fils est né,
j’ai voulu le rapporter
au SAV.
Sauf que le SAV des bébés,
ça n’existe pas.
Non pas que mon bébé était défectueux,
en fait, c’est moi qui n’allais pas bien.
Rien d’étonnant à cela,
je vais vous raconter pourquoi.
Certaines femmes vivent la maternité
comme sur un petit nuage.
Ce ne fut pas mon cas.
J’ai souffert d’hyperémèse gravidique.
C’est moche, hein ?
Rien que le nom, ça ne donne pas envie.
En d’autres termes,
vomissements incontrôlables
et nausées sévères et persistantes.
Comme à bord d’un bateau
en pleine tempête,
le mal de mer ne me quittera pas
jusqu’à l’accouchement.
Sans traitement approprié,
les symptômes sont inévitables :
grosse perte de poids, déshydratation
et carences nécessitant l’hospitalisation.
À ma souffrance physique s’est ajoutée
une souffrance psychologique.
J’ai pu entendre des phrases telles que :
« Hum, là, vous vomissez votre bébé,
(Rires)
est-ce que vous l’avez vraiment voulu ?
- Euh oui, carrément ! »
« Estime-toi heureuses,
au moins, tu ne grossis pas. »
À choisir, j’aurais préféré
prendre du poids.
Et la plus violente de toutes :
« Il faut souffrir pour être mère. »
D’accord !
Donc, parce que des milliards
de femmes l’ont fait avant moi,
je suis censée savoir le faire aussi.
Et en plus, en silence.
Je suis arrivée à terme dans un état de
fatigue physique et psychologique intense.
Impossible de vivre mon accouchement
en pleine conscience.
J’ai subi, j’ai obéi à l’équipe médicale,
si bien que j’ai fait une croix
sur mon plan de naissance.
Une fois rentrée chez moi
avec mon bébé sous le bras,
je suis passée en mode robot
pendant plusieurs mois.
Je me suis occupée de lui avec
trop peu de sentiments à son égard,
ou alors très mitigés.
À ce moment-là, je ne me sentais pas mère,
et - on me le dira plus tard -
j’étais en pleine dépression.
Alors, j’en ai conscience,
mon expérience est extrême et rare,
et heureusement d'ailleurs.
Mais elle a eu l’avantage
de titiller ma curiosité
et m’a permis d’en parler
ouvertement avec d’autres mères.
Souvent, j’ai eu l’impression
de briser un tabou,
comme si on avait pour habitude
de taire ce qui ne va pas
durant la grossesse, l’accouchement
et les premiers mois de l’enfant.
Comme si cette période
était une sorte de bulle
où tout devait paraître
fantastique et merveilleux.
Et pourtant, depuis quelques années,
les langues se délient un peu,
notamment grâce aux réseaux sociaux
et à une poignée d’humoristes
qui s’est emparée du sujet
et tente d'éveiller les consciences
à travers le rire.
Oui, ce sont toutes des femmes.
Et dans notre chère société patriarcale,
quoi de moins crédible qu’une femme
qui parle de problèmes de femmes ?
Mais heureusement,
nous disposons d’alliés de taille
pour faire entendre notre voix.
Et vous les connaissez.
Je parle bien évidemment des...
Public : Des hommes !
Des chiffres, voyons !
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
J’ai appris qu’en France,
15% des femmes atteintes d’hyperémèse
gravidique avaient recours à l’IVG.
Désespérées par le manque
de prise en charge,
certaines renonceraient
définitivement à devenir mère.
En 2018, on estimait à environ 20%
les jeunes mères souffrant
de dépression post-partum -
à ne pas confondre avec le baby blues
au retour de la maternité.
Hé oui, la dépression post-partum,
c’est du sérieux.
Dans la période 2013-2015, à égalité
avec les maladies cardio-vasculaires,
la première cause
de mortalité maternelle -
on parle donc de mort de la mère
dans l’année suivant l’accouchement -
n’est nul autre que le suicide.
Ces quelques chiffres - et il y en a
malheureusement beaucoup d’autres -
mettent en évidence la grande solitude
dans laquelle trop de femmes
se retrouvent.
Mais alors, que se passe-t-il ?
Pourquoi autant de drames ?
À bien y réfléchir,
le dispositif est assez brutal.
D’abord, vous êtes suivie de très près
par un obstétricien et une sage-femme
tout au long de votre grossesse.
Ensuite, en salle de naissance, vos
constantes ainsi que celles de votre bébé
sont surveillées par tout un tas
de machines et une équipe entière.
On vous dit quoi faire, comment
le faire et quand le faire.
Vous êtes un train sur des rails,
direction le terminus.
Et à peine quelques jours plus tard,
vous vous retrouvez chez vous,
seule bien sûr,
puisque votre conjoint n’a pas d’autre
option que de reprendre le travail,
avec le devoir d’être une mère,
et ce, sans transition.
Pour vous donner un exemple, imaginez que
l’on impose à un enfant de devenir adulte
sans passer par l'adolescence.
Vous êtes d’accord que ça en donnerait
une personne un peu perturbée, non ?
Eh bien, devenir mère, c'est pareil,
c'est tout un processus.
Et d’ailleurs, ça porte un nom,
ça s’appelle la « matrescence »,
contraction des mots
« maternité » et « adolescence ».
Alors comment la rendre la plus douce
possible, cette matrescence ?
Pour commencer, il serait bon
de déculpabiliser les mères.
Nous pourrions établir quelques règles
simples et voilà ce que je vous propose.
C’est ok de ne pas éprouver
de plaisir à être enceinte
et ce, quel que soit le trimestre.
C’est ok
de ne pas considérer l’accouchement
comme le plus beau jour de votre vie
et de ne pas vivre de véritable coup
de foudre à la découverte de votre bébé.
C’est ok de ne pas allaiter
ou au contraire de nourrir votre enfant
tant qu’il en exprime le besoin.
C’est ok d’avoir l’impression
que la situation vous échappe.
Vous n’avez sans doute pas
été assez préparée.
Beaucoup de futures mères
ne soupçonnent pas toujours
ce à quoi elles vont être
confrontées après l’accouchement.
Sans forcément parler de période horrible,
le post-partum peut être
une phase délicate
et au même titre que l’accouchement,
il se prépare.
Ma sage-femme m’avait bien
briefée sur l’accouchement,
mais alors l’après,
ça restait un vrai mystère.
J’avais lu quelques livres, certes,
mais j’étais à 10 000 lieues d’imaginer
ce qui pouvait se passer
dans mon corps et dans ma tête.
Aujourd’hui encore, nous sommes
en déficit d’information
et la remise en question
s’impose dès la grossesse.
Constat alarmant : les femmes
enceintes ne sont pas assez écoutées.
Vous connaissez bien sûr le célèbre
« Oh ! Arrête !
Tu es enceinte, pas malade. »
Alors non, vous n'êtes pas malade.
Mais cela ne vous oblige pas à taire
tous les petits maux de grossesse.
Et d’ailleurs, pourquoi les appelle-t-on
les petits maux ?
Nausées, somnolence, hémorroïdes,
douleurs ligamentaires, sciatique,
et j'en passe.
Pourquoi ces maux
deviendraient-ils supportables
dès qu’ils concernent une femme enceinte ?
Vous connaissez votre corps.
Souffrir ne fera pas de vous
une meilleure mère.
Au contraire,
vous êtes la seule à pouvoir estimer
s’il s’agit de petits maux
ou si vous avez réellement besoin d’aide.
Au début de mon hyperémèse,
on m’a ri au nez.
Il a fallu que je me batte
pour me faire entendre.
J’ai dû consulter plusieurs spécialistes
pour identifier ma pathologie
et réussir à aller -
oui -
jusqu’à l’accouchement.
En parlant d’accouchement.
En Allemagne,
si la future mère n’est pas emballée par
l’environnement surmédicalisé d’un hôpital
mais qu’elle craint
d’accoucher à domicile,
il lui est possible de se rendre
en maison de naissance.
Une alternative qui offre une approche
plus physiologique de l'accouchement.
Pas mal, hein ?
Vous voulez accoucher debout ?
C’est possible.
Vous voulez accoucher dans l’eau ?
Vous voulez accoucher sous hypnose ?
C'est possible.
En gros, vous voulez maîtriser
votre accouchement de A à Z.
C’est the place to be pour ça.
Bien sûr, on y accouche
naturellement, sans péridurale.
Alors certains diront :
« Ah ! Nous sommes en 2022.
Pourquoi accoucher dans la douleur ?
Il faut vraiment être maso.
On n’est pas des sauvages. »
Et si on oubliait les scènes
d’accouchement horribles
que l’on voit dans les films,
avec des cris de douleur atroces,
les pieds dans les étriers ?
Oui, l’injection d’endorphine de synthèse,
que l’on appelle la péridurale,
rend l'accouchement indolore.
Enfin, si elle est bien posée.
Pourtant, la nature est bien faite.
Sentir les contractions sans les subir,
votre corps sait le faire tout seul.
Vous pouvez faire confiance à une
stupéfiante combinaison d’hormones,
une vraie course de relais :
la fameuse ocytocine
pour faciliter le travail,
la relaxine pour préparer le terrain,
l’adrénaline pour vous donner
la force d’accoucher,
l’endorphine pour neutraliser la douleur
et enfin la prolactine
pour déclencher la montée de lait.
Pour que votre corps les produise en
quantité suffisante et que la magie opère,
il est important de respecter
cinq éléments essentiels :
vous sentir en sécurité, profiter du
silence, de l’obscurité, de la chaleur,
et enfin être dans l’intimité.
Je ne sais pas vous, mais je n'ai pas
l'impression que ce soit possible ici.
Par contre, là,
c’est quand même plus cocooning.
Les conditions ont l’air réunies pour
que les hormones fassent leur travail.
Donner naissance peut être une épreuve,
mais c’est probablement la partie
la plus simple de la matrescence.
C'est naturel.
Par contre, prendre ses marques
à l’arrivée d’un nouveau petit
humain livré sans mode d’emploi,
ça peut être plus difficile,
notamment durant ce qu’on
appelle la chute d’hormones,
un état de fatigue intense qui succède
à l’euphorie de la naissance.
En Angleterre, au 16ᵉ siècle, il était
courant qu’à l’approche de l’accouchement,
les femmes de l’entourage direct
emménagent de manière temporaire
chez la future mère.
Complémentaire à la sage-femme,
leur rôle était de préparer la chambre,
rester près de la femme en travail, lui
préparer à manger, lui faire des tisanes,
l'encourager, la réconforter, la prendre
dans leurs bras, la masser, la caresser,
prier et chanter.
Imaginez-vous être entourée
de celles en qui vous avez confiance ?
Perso, j'aurais adoré que ma mère
et ma sœur soient à mes côtés.
Une fois l’accouchement terminé,
ces femmes restaient pendant
encore une quarantaine de jours
pour transmettre leur expérience de mère.
Vous avez bien entendu :
une quarantaine de jours.
Cette pratique a perduré en Europe
jusqu’à il n’y a pas si longtemps.
Et dans la tradition chinoise,
il s’agit du fameux « mois d’or ».
Cette période est synonyme
d’adaptation et de récupération,
aussi bien physique que mentale.
Et la mère fait l’objet
de toutes les attentions.
Là aussi, mère, sœur, amie, voisine,
quel que soit leur rang social,
se relaient auprès d’elle
pour la dorloter.
Leur mission : l’aider
à devenir une mère accomplie.
En Chine,
le mois d’or est un réel
investissement sur l’avenir
et cette pratique résonne
avec cet adage que l’on entend souvent :
« Maman heureuse,
bébé heureux. »
Aussi, peut-être avez-vous entendu
parler des « kraamzorg » ?
Pour les cinéphiles,
rien à voir avec le méchant Zorg
dans le film « Le cinquième élément ».
Aux Pays-Bas, chaque femme qui accouche
a le droit de solliciter une aide-maman
dès sa sortie de la maternité.
Et je vous rassure, elle ne ressemble
pas à ça, mais plutôt à ça.
Cette véritable fée néerlandaise
s’implique dans la vie du foyer
pendant plusieurs jours.
Elle gère l’intendance, conseille pour
l’allaitement et veille au soin du bébé.
Et ce, malgré la présence du co-parent.
Co-parent qui malheureusement
ne reste pas toujours.
Dans les pays nordiques,
on joue la carte de l’égalité
pour démarrer cette nouvelle vie à trois.
Saviez-vous que les pères islandais
bénéficient de 90 jours
de congé paternité ?
C'est autant que pour la mère.
Comme ça, pas de jaloux.
En Norvège, les parents ont au total
un an de congés payés à se partager.
Un an.
Les pères ont même pour obligation
de poser quatre mois au minimum.
Vous l’aurez compris, donner la vie,
bien que les femmes le fassent depuis
des milliers d’années, n’est pas inné.
La grossesse, l’accouchement et le
post-partum peuvent être violents
et passer au travers de ces épreuves
en étant seule l’est encore plus.
Être écoutée, être informée, être
accompagnée, ça change tout.
Par la famille, par les amis,
par le personnel médical,
mais par le personnel paramédical aussi.
Certaines femmes passionnées
en ont même fait leur métier.
On les appelle les « doulas ».
L’écoute, l’empathie et la bienveillance
sont au cœur de leurs pratiques.
Grâce à leur propre expérience de mère
et à une formation sérieuse,
elles vous accompagnent,
elles vous soutiennent,
du début de la grossesse
jusqu’à la fin du post-partum.
Elles peuvent même vous accompagner
en maison de naissance pour accoucher.
Pas étonnant que les femmes fassent
de plus en plus appel à elles.
Pour autant, il serait vraiment dangereux
de se passer de l'accompagnement médical
que nous avons la chance
d’avoir à disposition aujourd’hui.
Mais en s’inspirant du passé
et de ce qui se fait ailleurs,
nous pourrions imaginer replacer
les émotions et les besoins de la femme
au cœur d’un dispositif.
Un dispositif qui s’articule autour
de la santé, oui, mais du bien-être aussi,
physique et mental,
comme, par exemple, une maison
de naissance adossée à un hôpital,
comme c’est le cas aux Bluets, à Paris.
Bon.
Vous l’aurez compris,
je l’ai finalement gardé mon bébé,
(Rires)
et je ne le rapporterais
pour rien au monde.
Mais il m'a fallu du temps
pour m'en remettre.
Beaucoup trop de temps.
Et tout comme il n’existe pas
de SAV des bébés,
il n’existe pas non plus
de SAV des mamans.
Et parce qu’il vaut mieux
prévenir que guérir,
je suis persuadée que durant
toutes les phases de la matrescence,
notre devoir est d’offrir
les meilleures conditions aux femmes
pour qu’elles puissent devenir
les mères qu’elles ont envie d’être.
Là, nous jouons très gros et ce qui nous
manque, c’est une toute petite passerelle,
une passerelle qui viendrait
gommer cette dualité,
une passerelle qui viendrait connecter
ces deux mondes : tradition et modernité.
Alors prenons le meilleur des deux,
tout simplement.
(Applaudissements)